or we can speak now to the shadow
chancellor rachel reeves uh before we
get on to uh those strikes and some of
the labour policy i just want to come
off the back of the interview we've just
had to talk about uh northern ireland
brandon lewis there saying that the
legislation published tomorrow will not
break the law do you believe him
well we haven't seen the legislation yet
but it does look like the government
plan to break international law now this
government seemed to be developing a
record for law breaking and it's not one
that the labour party can support but we
help bring in the good friday agreement
we are deeply passionately committed to
it we want the northern ireland protocol
to work but we know
to to get it to work we have to
negotiate and work with our european
partners now kia stammer was in belfast
and dublin last week talking to leaders
talking to businesses showing the
leadership that frankly is lacking from
the prime minister today
so it's um what exactly uh do you want
to happen then with the northern ireland
protocol
there's some very practical things
sophie that could happen pretty much
straight away the first would be to get
a bespoke veterinary agreement between
the eu and the uk to help sp speed up
the movement of goods and services not
just between northern ireland and the
rest of of britain but also between the
uk and um
and the rest of the european uh union
new zealand has got a veterinary
agreement with the eu it can't be on
beyond the wit of the eu and the uk to
negotiate one of those so you don't have
this huge bureaucracy and delays at the
border which are causing so many many
problems particularly in northern
ireland but also at dover as well so
there are practical things like that
that require statecraft they require a
building of trust and those are the
things that boris johnson has not been
able to do
and those skills and those abilities i
believe that kia stammer has those in
spades
right let's talk about the strikes then
it's something that many of our viewers
are going to be really concerned about
in the weeks and months ahead um
according to the sunday telegraph today
the government's reportedly ready
to remove a legal restriction that was
introduced under tony blair that would
prevent employers hiring agency workers
to cover striking staff would you back
the use of agency workers
it just doesn't make any sense the way
to resolve this is to get people around
the table but the idea that you can
replace a skilled train signaler with an
agency worker would you feel safe going
on a train knowing that it was an agency
worker rather than a properly skilled
and trained up trained signaler i know
that i wouldn't so instead of this uh
fanning the flames and increasing
tensions the government needs to act
like firefighters rather than arsonists
and try and get some resolution to this
because the people that will pay the
price if these strikes go ahead
ordinarily working people who want to go
out to work people who need to get to
doctor's appointment and to
have operations in hospitals businesses
who after everything they've gone
through need their workers in the office
but also people who work in the train
industry will lose pay if they're not
going to work so nobody wants these
strikes to happen the government though
are not an observer in all of this
they're an actor and they need to be
getting people around the table and
resolving these disputes instead of
fanning the flames of the fire um this
week your shadow house secretary west
streeting said put it this way if i was
a member of the rmt and my job was at
risk like this then i would be voting to
go on strike would you be voting to go
on strike
well they've already um they've already
had those those those uh those votes
those decisions made but it's not too
late to avert the strikes and you know
what we're gonna come in
i'm going to have to come in on that
because that really wasn't a straight
answer at all would you be voting to go
on strike if you were an mt worker
well look i want to be the chancellor of
the exchequer sophie that is the job
that i aspire to do and if i was
chancellor of the exchequer today i
would be doing everything within my
power to avert these strikes that's what
people want from a government a
government that is on the side of
ordinary working people trying to uh to
resolve problems rather than to fan the
flames and that's the job that i want to
do i want to be the chancellor of this
great country and if i was chancellor i
would be doing everything i can to avoid
the huge disruption that will come from
strike actions and that's what i want to
see from this prime minister and this
chancellor i spoke to the uh rmt general
secretary lynch on the show a little
while ago and he said i've seen no
response from the labour front bench
that says we support the workers in
their struggles if we just get this
bland democratic party sitting in the
center of politics taking their
instructions off the daily mail not
getting behind worker struggles you have
to ask yourself why do they actually
call themselves the labour party
do you think he has got a point that
you're being a bit delayed
well look the labour party are the party
of working people the clue is in the
name and i'm incredibly proud of the
relationship between the labour party
and our trade unions and and unlike the
um the rail unions we don't want to see
agency workers uh uh coming in who are
not qualified to do jobs are putting
public uh um safety at uh at risk but
look we also want to do everything we
can to avert these strikes and i know
that the people who work in the trade
industry don't want these strikes to
happen either they want a government
that's on their side that tries to
resolve these disputes and as i say
sophie if i was in government today that
would be my number one priority
okay now today you're criticizing the
conservative party for what you're
calling its sticking plaster approach to
deep economic policies
um but just to talk about labour because
i've been asking labour politicians you
know for some weeks now you know what's
the big
transformative idea the vision if you
like from the labour party
annalise dodd says it's to buy make and
sell more in the country
mcfadden told me it's about 200 000
children living in areas with no
outstanding schools lisa nandy said good
clean jobs kierstama talked about a
windfall tax to reduce energy bills
i just can't help thinking you know it's
a reason that everyone seems to give a
different answer to this question
because there isn't a single big
transformative policy from the labour
party
well the great thing about those answers
sophia is it shows that labour party is
buzzing with ideas and indeed labour is
winning the battle of ideas in politics
today you see that with the u-turn from
the government on the windfall tax and i
remember speaking on your program back
in january when i first started calling
for a win for tax and government
ministers said oh we can't do that
because the energy companies are
struggling and it would stop investment
and five months later the government
bowed to the inevitable introduce that
windfall tax and you know if the toys
have run out of ideas and they clearly
have then we've got plenty more of them
as annalisa has said our plans to buy
make and sell more in britain as lisa
says our plans to ensure that every part
of the country has jobs that pay a
decent wage where the government matches
the ambition that people have for their
families and their communities so labor
party are buzzing with ideas under
kier's leadership we are winning uh the
votes of people who turned away from
labour at the last couple of uh
elections and will continue to set out
more of those ideas as i am to doing
today on labour's plans for a stronger
and more secure economy because as well
as that windfall tax which is much
needed to tackle the cost of living
crisis right now we do need more than a
sticking plaster approach we need to be
boosting our energy security our supply
chain security security for businesses
because only by doing those things will
we boost the economic security
of families and family finances right
across the country
now i know you are obviously a
kierstalmer loyalist but ever since of
course he said that he would resign uh
if durham police found against him
there's been lots of leadership
speculation it feels like every time
that we're streeting or lisa and nandy
open their mouths people see it as a
leadership pitch and i was just thinking
before this interview i'm not sure if
anyone's actually asked you the question
um
would you fancy a run at the leadership
at some point if the opportunity were to
arise
but there's not the opportunity is not
there you know kia is the leader of the
labour party i don't know although he
said quite rightly that if he is fined
well i said a moment ago you know i want
to be chancellor of the extract the only
thing i don't like about my job title
today is the shadow at the beginning of
it i want to be the child
i'm absolutely
i'm absolutely not saying first green
chance like that isn't what i want to do
i'm absolutely not saying that you're
not a kid i'm a loyalist and that's why
i sort of introduced a question with
that uh proviso but that is that is
definitely not a uh ruling out is it
but there's just there's no there's
nothing to there's nothing to see here
you know there's no leadership context
but at the point about kia saying that
he would resign if he was fined was to
show the contrast really between
kiyosama a man of honesty integrity of
decency he wants to restore those
values of trust and decency to politics
and public life compared to a rule
breaking a prime minister who has no
respect for the ministerial code uh for
the conduct of of politics and that's
why i'm so proud to uh to stand here as
a member of kia
shadow cabinet and why i'm so desperate
to get rid of this prime minister with a
bluster and the failure to rise to the
challenges of the country and at the
same time is lying and cheating uh that
is is
so discrediting this government and our
country
okay rachel reeves uh thank you very
much indeed rachel ruth says hello
chancellor thank you